[Música]
[Aplausos]
quisiera pedirles algo y es que si hacen
sus ojos en este momento e imagínense
que están en el océano
están disfrutando de el mar del sol de
la arena y de repente aparece un tiburón
abran sus ojos
pueden levantarme la mano quienes
pensaron en sangre
cuerpos mutilados quienes sintieron
miedo
muchísimas personas
bueno
esto que esté de siente se llama se la
cofom ya esto es básicamente miedo o
temor hacia los tiburones
hay una razón de ser
los estudios científicos pueden decir
que inclusive
genéticamente venimos con muchísimos
miedos sin embargo hollywood ha aportado
muchísimo a que este miedo esté presente
hemos visto pasar de los pasar de los
años muchísimas películas que nos
enseñan a tenerle miedo a los tiburones
sin embargo la realidad que ellos viven
es muy diferente
eso que ustedes pueden ver por acá es el
aleteo de tiburón una de las causas de
una posible extinción de tiburones
el aleteo tiburón es la práctica donde
el tiburón se saca del mar se cortan sus
aletas y se regresa vivo al mar
produciendo esto que tengan una muerte
muy lenta y muy dolorosa
como bueno
desangrándose
asfixiados porque no pueden respirar
ellos para poder respirar necesitan
estar en constante movimiento
o si no comidos vivos por otros animales
yo crecí y soy de playa sámara crecí en
un lugar donde se me enseñó a amar el
mar se me enseñó a respetar nuestro
ecosistema
tengo una mamá maravillosa que desde muy
pequeña me enseñó lo que era adentrarse
en el océano y conocerlo y esto me ha
permitido
e inculcarle esto mis hijas
el conocer el océano me ha enseñado no
solamente la importancia de él sino
también en la importancia que tiene la
importancia que tenemos que tomar en
cuanto a acciones para poder mantener
los años
porque se da el aleteo de tiburones
bueno
el aleta de tiburón de edad
para
poder realizar esto que ustedes ven por
acá esto que ven en la fotografía es una
sopa de aleta de tiburón
esta sopa de aleta tiburón en el mercado
asiático ronda entre los 150 y 200
dólares es un negocio muy lucrativo me
di cuenta de toda esta problemática
porque mi papá
estuvo involucrado en la actividad del
aleteo tiburón entonces imagínense como
a los 12 años me entero yo que uno de
los seres más importantes de mi vida se
dedica a una actividad tan cruel y tan
negativa para el ecosistema marino
porque es tan lucrativo bueno un kilo
aleta de tiburón ronda entre los 600 y
750 dólares imagínense
el muy buen negocio que esto deja sin
embargo estamos dejando a un lado el
daño que estamos haciendo
en una época muy difícil de mi vida es
cuando me entero de toda esta
problemática del aleteo y siempre mi
manera de
de alejarme de los problemas ha sido en
el océano en el mar
decidí investigar un poco más sobre los
tiburones porque son importantes porque
les hacen tanto daño
y descubrí muchísimo
sin embargo descubrí que tenemos
muchísimas similitudes con ellos
descubrí que me identificaba con ellos
los tiburones son
animales sumamente incomprendidos
ellos
a primera vista lo que podemos ver es un
animal grande fuerte que no tiene
ninguna problemática
y lo más irónico de todo es que tienen
450 millones de años de estar en nuestro
planeta mucho más que los dinosaurios y
en los últimos 70 años nos hemos
dedicado a exterminar los estamos
hablando que por año
eliminamos entre 70 a 100 millones de
tiburones en todo el mundo
el problema es que los tiburones se
reproducen muy lento
entonces los cálculos para las
matemáticas acá no nos ayudan con estos
números
después
de estar sumergida en una gran depresión
y encontrarás el rumbo que quería
que quería tomar decidí investigar un
poco sobre lo que era fertilización in
vitro y me pregunte será que podemos
aplicarlo en tiburones
han sido años de investigación han sido
años de trabajo duro que están dando
frutos
siempre ha sido una persona que
no he tenido como confianza en mí misma
el estar en una carrera como ingeniería
creo que
entre sus beneficios hizo mucho que está
rodeada de tantos hombres y demás me
hiciera entender que los hombres hoy en
día cuando demuestra demuestran su
título universitario
dicen yo soy el ingeniero tal nadie duda
en sus capacidades como mujeres hemos
tenido el reto de demostrarlo todos los
días
y creo que por primera vez lo digo con
mucha alegría y mucho entusiasmo porque
este espacio se me ha permitido conocer
me a mí misma y es que he logrado
fertilizar in vitro tiburones y en
ningún lugar del mundo se está dando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
puedo decir que este país es tan
pequeñito donde tenemos tanta naturaleza
tanta biodiversidad
nos puede dar muchísimo más
estos que ven por acá son como los bebés
y mi sueño es poder replicar este modelo
y poder
asumir el compromiso y poder atacar esta
problemática
y bien si la investigación científica
sumamente importante hay otro tema que
tenemos que abarcar
qué es la educación ambiental no podemos
proteger un animal que nos atemoriza no
podemos proteger a algo que simplemente
si entramos al océano nos da miedo
actividades como limpiezas de playa
charlas educativas nos permiten
no solamente cambiar esa perspectiva
'negativa' hacia los tiburones sino
también pasar esa información de
generación en generación
en todos estos años dando charlas no
solamente logrado enseñar la importancia
de los tiburones sino también he
aprendido que la gente está dispuesto a
escuchar que la gente está dispuesta a
entender
y eso me ha permitido poder impactar
positivamente
este año he podido estar en muchos
espacios en donde me han ayudado
personalmente a crecer como persona ya
crecer en mí ya creer en mí misma
y he buscado ese apoyo en red de mujeres
realmente en lo que llamamos una tribu
que nos ha enseñado muchísimo a todas
y esto me motiva a seguir enseñando que
los tiburones son más que solo aletas
ellos están para dar más
a como nosotros los necesitamos para que
mantenga los océanos limpios porque son
los que se comen los puestos enfermos
para que mantenga la cadena alimenticia
en orden y los arrecifes de coral sigan
y que son importantes porque los océanos
básicamente el pulmón el pulmón del
planeta que nos da
muchísima cantidad de oxígeno
me ha enseñado también
aparte que los tiburones son más que
solo aletas
a decirle a la gente y contarle a la
gente
que no se asusten si ven un tiburón en
el mar
asústense cuando no los vean en él
ahora
quisiera hacerles una pregunta
yo solar mi hijo ingeniera escenógrafa
me comprometo a seguir luchando por
salvar tiburones a seguir replicando
modelos de investigación científica para
evitar una posible extinción
y ustedes están dispuestos a hacer ese
cambio y a luchar por los tiburones
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]